terrible de l'actualité de ce dimanche
parce qu'après les millions du tennis
l'actualité en France ce dimanche
commence par un très émouvant cri de
colère de l'abbé Pierre un homme de 78
ans lui-même en très mauvaise santé mais
qui se lance dans une nouvelle campagne
en faveur des plus déshérités l'abé
pierre estime à 2 millions le nombre de
Français très mal logés et à 400000 le
nombre des sans abris aucun ce matin à
titre d'exemple et bien il a rendu
visite à une trentaine de personnes dans
le 19e arrondissement de Paris qui ont
été expulsé de leur logement véuste et
qui préfère camper dans la rue plutôt
que d'accepter un relogement provisoire
reporter Anne mourg et Frédéric Basil à
78 ans l'abbé Pierre une nouvelle fois
au secours des plus démunis un pauvre
parmi les pauvres ces 34 personnes
habité en toute légalité dans un
immeuble le logement a été déclaré
insalubre les habitants hommes femmes et
enfants ont été expulsés un mois et demi
après la ville de Paris ne les a pas
encore
relogé la France éat de barbarie d'avoir
je ne sais pas le nombre mais c'est
beaucoup plusieurs millions d'habitants
hommes femme et enfants pour lesquels la
France est obligé d'avouer pour vous
êtes de trop pour vous au lieu au point
de vue de l'habitat qu'on ne vienneent
jamais nous dire que pour des
souffrances comme cell-là ça coûte trop
cher c'est
intolérable depuis un mois et demi ils
vivent dehors dans des abris de fortune
ils ignorent toujours dansbi de temps
ils retrouveront un toit un vrai pour la
ville de Paris avant de trouver ce
logement il faut patienter les listes
d'attentes sont déjà longues on leur a
fait des propositions notamment de
relogement provisoire qu'elle refuse
c'est leur problème encore une fois
Paris ne peut pas reloger tous les
demandeurs de logement de Paris de la
banlieu et de la province et même de
l'étranger il y a un choix à faire il y
a 50000 demandeurs de logement l'abbé
Pierre l'a promis il soutiendra les 3400
abris jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve un nouveau
toi bien à
eux c'est une